a mission of equity are you going to
join the mission of equity
can you define it lieutenant colonel
matthew lohmeyer can define it he knows
what mission looks like he was a
commander in the space force he was then
fired for speaking out against the open
political indoctrination that he saw
there
he's the author of the book irresistible
revolution marxism's goal of conquest
and the unmaking of the american
military
colonel meyer joins us tonight uh listen
carl thanks so much
for coming on so nasa
you would think would be the one branch
agency that would be
immune from the equity mission
were you i mean you served in the us
government for a long time were you
under the impression that nasa had a
problem with discrimination in years
past
yeah i don't know tucker thanks first
off for having me on your show
and as always i don't speak for the
defense department but speak for myself
you know i'm i don't think that any of
our institutions at this point
are immune from this idea that we're
going to be pursuing equity
uh clearly these are hot topics uh
the the talking point of the day in fact
i do want to define it for the american
people you mentioned i know the
definition of equity
it's important for the american people
to understand
the difference between equity and
equality
one of them is good and the ideal
and the other is not good uh we tend to
confuse at the moment
equality of opportunity which is the
ideal and is something that's
a part of america's founding philosophy
with equity it's a new it's a new term
it's it's used wittingly which
essentially means
enforced outcomes or enforced inequality
in fact
based on what i've seen in the
department of defense and now what i'm
hearing
is permeating institutions across the
country
it's essentially even potentially uh
illegally discriminatory uh policy
uh equity is not good as it is defined
but it sounds good and that's why we use
the word
but nasa has historically been
i think a symbol of inclusion and
equal opportunity yes nasa is the kind
of an organization
that people can look at and understand
that regardless of your background
you're able to show up here just like in
the defense department
and rise up based on your merit and have
an opportunity to make a name for
yourself to rise to leadership and
actually do very important things for
the country
because there's a unifying mission uh
that these institutions
uh believe in whether it's space
exploration in the case of nasa
or uh defending uh our country and our
allies
from serious threats that we have in the
world people in uniform for example
rally around that mission and yes have
historically not been
caught up in the kind of identity
politicking that you're talking about
that i'm hearing
uh in your monologue and so i'll just
make one point to say that
i think our senior leaders and our
national leaders need to think
very carefully about whether or not they
want to inject
tribalism into our are long trusted
institutions in this country that
typically have not been infected with
tribal thinking with all that that
entails do we really want to walk the
road
that will cause us to abandon martin
luther king jr's
dream of having a colorless society
where
in fact were starting once again to
judge people and
by the color of their skin impugning
guilt to other
groups of people based on their group
identity not because of anything that
they've ever done
necessarily themselves but based on who
they are
accidentally even let's say that is a
good definition of racism
we don't impugn guilt to people based on
the color of their skin
no and we never should and i always
imagined
the military was the shining beacon of
what the rest of the country should be
because it was a colorblind meritocracy
in there
so i think this threatens all of us um
yeah
the the military is great at that tucker
and uh that's why so many people are
upset about what they're hearing
yeah and they have every reason to be i
know that you are thank you thank you
for speaking out and for coming on
tonight
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else